>> SPEAKER: Wait one more
minute, and then we'll get
started.
>> SPEAKER: One awkward minute.
>> SPEAKER: All right, well,
thanks for coming, everybody.
We're going to get started.  Um,
I'm just here to introduce Jer.
Welcome to the Library of
Congress and to this very
special addition of Artist in
the Archive.
I'm  Abby Potter, I'm the acting
chief of the Library of Congress
Lab, which is also known as
National Digital Initiatives,
and I have the pleasure to
introduce our host for tonight,
the wonderful Jer Thorp.  He
comes to us from New York City
by way of Vancouver.
He's an artist and educator
exploring the many boundaries
between science, art and
culture.  His work has been
published in many
magazines, like magazines.  He
was the data artist and
residence at the New York Times
and is a National
Geographic fellow, a
Rockefeller Foundation fello and
co-founder of the Office of
Creative Research.
Jer is also the current
innovator Innovator-in-Residence
here at the library.  He is part
of a program to bring people
here with creative ideas and a
wide array of experiences and
backgrounds to do new and
interesting
things with our collections of
data.  In his time with us, he
has certainly done this.
He has wrangled our MARC records
and made beautiful and
thoughtful entryways into our
collections, he's traversed all
of our tunnels and made friends
with people he's come across,
and he's exposed the vastness
and  smallness of this
institution.  He's applied his
talents to translating the
intangibles of the Library of
Congress to an audience that may
not know that much about us, and
this podcast is a great example
of that, and I'm really  looking
forward to
tonight's episode, and, um, as
we go about the recording, since
we are live streaming, just if
you can wait to applause at his
signal, and he says it will be
obvious.
(Laughing.)
>> SPEAKER: All right.
(Off mic.)
>> SPEAKER: The beginning.
>> SPEAKER: Gene Edwards, 2001.
>> SPEAKER: The beginning, a
novel.
>> SPEAKER: In the beginning,
selected poem --
>> SPEAKER: In the beginning --
(
(Inaudible.
)
>> SPEAKER: In the beginning
was the end, 1989.
>> SPEAKER: 1997.
>> SPEAKER: The beginning
place.
>> SPEAKER: The beginning of
difficulty difficulty, 1989, 58
pages.
>> SPEAKER: The beginning of
calamity,
Tom House, 288 pages.
>> SPEAKER: The beginnings of
American literature, 1965, 324
pages.
(Inaudible.)
>> SPEAKER: The beginnings of
critical
realism in America.  Map of the
canal route at the beginning of
the American Occupation.
>> SPEAKER: CR Jones, 1935.
>> SPEAKER: In this, the
beginning of
Japan's fifth year of their
declared war.
>> SPEAKER: 1993.
>> SPEAKER: Appearance of
phenomenon immediately after the
beginning of totality.
(Off mic.
)
>> SPEAKER: Two men supporting
the motorcycles near Boise,
Idaho.
(Off mic.)
>> SPEAKER: General and Mrs.
William  Mitchell training young
dogs at the beginning of the
quail season.
(Off mic.)
>> SPEAKER: Evacuation of
government buildings was
orderly, as sirens sounded the
start of a giant civil defense
exercise.
(Off mic.)
>> SPEAKER: The beginnings of
naturalism and American fiction,
a study
of the works of  Hamland Garland
-- with special reference to
some European influences.
>> SPEAKER: 1961.
>> SPEAKER: A Negro girl sings
and claps her hand as DC
national guard trucks roll along
the Constitution Avenue here,
August 28th, before the start of
the Civil Rights March on
Washington.
>> SPEAKER: New York telegram,
1963.
(Off mic.
)
>> SPEAKER: There should be
audio here, but the audio is
not, can you check the audio
feed from this?
We're going to edit this part
out.
(Laughing.
)
>> SPEAKER: I'll try it one
more time.
All right, well, there's going
to be audio there.
Hello, and welcome to another
episode of the Artist in the
Archive.  If you've already been
listening to our podcast, you
probably know what to expect,
but for all new listeners, let
me take a minute to catch up.
I'm Jer Thorp, a writer and
teacher and artist from
Brooklyn.  Last year, they asked
me to come here and spend six
months as the
Innovator-in-Residence.
This invitation was exciting and
nebulous enough that I jumped at
the opportunity, and since
October, I've been wondering
through the halls, thinking
about how the institution's
enormous data stores might be
put to novel and creative uses.
Along the way, I've talked to so
very many interesting people and
have had the chance to see so
very, very many interesting
things.  Now, this podcast is a
chance to share those
interesting things and people
with you and to share the work
I've been doing.
Now, this episode is a little
bit different.  For starters,
I'm recording this in front of
an audience.  Hi, everyone.
We're also doing this in the
grand surroundings,  well, much
grander
surroundings than at home in
Brooklyn.
We're in the Jefferson Building
at the Library of Congress.
It's kind of an amazing room,
right?
Let me see, how can I describe
it to you, all of you who aren't
here?  Oh, I know, Joel, can you
describe it for us?
>> SPEAKER: Why not?
I would say that this high
ceiling room, first of all, it's
rectangular, about the size of
one-half of a tennis
court, each wall is topped by a
white railing, as one might see
on a balcony.
Below it a long strip of white,
extending along each side of the
room.  Below this ornamental
prop are square panels in two
shades of yellow.
Lighting is set behind, glowing
toward the ceiling.
Five rows of chairs with a
center aisle are set facing a
platform with two  chairs.
Behind this arrangement is a
large
wood cabinet, flanked on the
left by the United States flag,
and on the right, by the blue
flag of the Library of Congress.
To the left of the U.S.
flag is an exit, and then a
candle candleobruwith three
glowing lights, highlighting a
head and shoulders
portrait of a stern-faced
gentleman.
To the right of the flag is a
glass case with wood supporters
on display,
and then a  sculpture in black.
The sculpture depicts a male and
a
female nude, in an embrace, sans
kiss, while seated.  The man's
right arm rests on the female's
left thigh.  The left side of
the room features three glass
case displays.
In the center, a violin cello
flanked by two cases, each
containing a violin.
The right side of the room has
four rectangular windows windows
with French doors in the center.
The doors are set beside a
taught wrought-iron gate.  On
each side of the gate, at center
is
the delegate wrought-iron design
of a violin.  At the rear of the
room is a black sculpture of two
nudes.
At left, a female is on her
knees, reaching up in the
embrace and kiss of a seated
male.  Behind this display is
the ramp you may have used to
enter the room.  On the wall to
the right of the ramp
is a tapestry, depicting a
forest scene
with eight individuals in
medieval dress.  The room is
carpeted in a blue and green
floral pattern, with pink
blossoms, and finally, for this
presentation, two large screen
displays are at the left and
right of the
platform in the front of the
room.
>> SPEAKER: Joel is a true
pioneer in the field of audio
description.  For almost 40
years, he's been describing
events for the blind and
visually-impaired.
To pick just a few of the
projects, they've produced audio
descriptions for sesame Street,
the National  Park
Service, and for the
presidential
inauguration parades in 2009 and
2013.  Tell me a little bit
about audio description.
>> SPEAKER: Well, thank you.
I'm happy to, because it's,
ironically
enough, it's
a technique that needs
visibility visibility.  The
title of my book on audio
description, published in in
2014, is The Visual Made Verbal,
and that's what description is.
It's a translation of visual
images to
words, succinct words that are
imaginative, to convey that
visual image of television, of
film, of theater, of
dance, of opera, museum
displays, to, um, a significant
population.
In this country alone, there are
over
21 million Americans who are
either blind or, to quote
American Foundation
of Blind, or have trouble
seeing, even with correction.
21 million, that's 8 percent of
the population.
>> SPEAKER: Well, we're going
to hear from Joel a few times
today.  One of the things I
discovered from recording this
podcast about the library and
all the amazing objects is just
how difficult it is to give a
good description of things, and
I knew that
people who were  lissing to the
podcast who might not be able to
see what we're talking about or
to look at a picture would
benefit tremendously from Joel's
work, so thank you, Joel, and
we'll hear from you a little bit
later.  Now, of all the
mysterious and wonderful nooks
and crannies of this place,
perhaps the most delightful, and
certainly the most intriguingly
named is
the catburg feed, home to the
library's poetry department.
The room overlooks the Grand
Hall to one side and the roof of
the Capitol to the other.  In
summary, I think it's fair to
see that our first guest has one
of the best  offices in the
world.  Robert is head of the
poetry and literature center of
the Library of Congress.  Hello,
Robert, and welcome to Artist in
the Archive.  Come on up.
>> SPEAKER: Hi.
>> SPEAKER: Um, Robert, your
permanence
is different department is
different from a lot of the
others, not only because you
have the best office, um, but
also because, unlike all the
other departments, or most of
the other departments, you're
not necessarily a collecting
department.  If I go up to the
poetry office, I'm not going to
find stacks and stacks of
poetry.
Instead, maybe, I'm going to
find poets.
>> SPEAKER: You may.
You'll definitely find us, but
there
are a number of divisions in
terms of
the library that are not
collection- collection-based.
>> SPEAKER: Can you tell us, I
think
all of us have heard, um, about
the poet laureate, but we might
have some confusion as to what
they do.  Can you tell us what
the poet laureate does?
>> SPEAKER: The poet laureate
position was originally called
the consultant in poetry
position, it was established
around 80 years ago by the
Library of Congress.  Um, it was
changed by an act of
Congress in 1985 to the current
title, the poet laureate
consultant in poetry at the
Library of Congress, a real
mouthful.
Um, the poet laureate, according
to
the law, is selected by the
librarian of Congress based
entirely on merit, and there
isn't really anything that a
poet laureate has to do in the
position.
We usually have them give an
opening reading and a closing
talk to kick off our literary
season in September and end
things at the end of April,
beginning of May, but other than
that, really, the
laureate serves as an ambassador
for the art and represents the
office and the
library.
>> SPEAKER: And you've had some
pretty
amazing American poets as poet
laureate.
The most recent poet laureate,
Tracy Cay Smith.  I didn't ask
you here to talk about poet
laureates though, I asked you
here
to show everybody and to talk
about maybe my favorite object
that I've had
the chance to see while I've
been here, and this is sitting
on the table in front of us, and
what it is, actually, why don't
you tell us what it is?
>> SPEAKER: Sure.
Um, when I started at the
library
about seven years ago, I found
this book in one of the, um,
drawers of the old
furniture that we had given to
us
notably in the early 40s, the
person for whom this room is
named.  This is a book that says
on its cover,  Poets Corner.
I opened it up to realize that
it has all the days of the year
and signatures
of, um, various poets and
writers and even a few Library
of Congress staff who
have been up in the office for
events or what have you, and it
covers, basically,
the 80 years of the office's
history.  So, you have all sorts
of wonderful things, and you
have a lot of people who aren't
famous in there.
>> SPEAKER: Let's take a moment
to describe this book, Joel.
>> SPEAKER: Sure.
This is a small diary,
rectangular shaped, situated
vertically.  The edges of its
brown front are slightly worn,
although it is adorned
with gold ornamentation, lines
that frame the shape.
To the right at center is a
brass lock.  At bottom in gold
lettering, Poets Corners.  The
book's pages are lined
horizontally, and at the top of
each page is the month and date.
At the top left of each page is
printed the number 19.
>> SPEAKER: So, yeah, so, this
object fascinates me, and I'll
tell you why.  It's because, um,
every poet who has done a
reading at the library has
signed this book.  Well, let's
say most of them, an awful lot
of them.
(Laughing.)
>> SPEAKER: And they signed it
across the span of many, many
decades.  Do you know what the
earliest signature in the book
is?
>> SPEAKER: I think the
earliest
signature is from the early 40s,
but I wouldn't know whose it was
or when it
was, but I think we discovered
one from 1941 or 42.
>> SPEAKER: So, along with
that, you might have a signature
from last week, and the way the
book is organized, and
by the way, it's called Poets
Corner, I love this, what this
was intended for was for a poet,
and the poet would write, they
would write their poetry in it,
sort of day by day, and it would
be
a way to collect your poems, but
instead
of doing that, you've collected
poets in this book.  Every page
in this book is a day in the
year, 365 pages, and they're all
signed by different people.  So,
if we picked a page at random,
Robert, can you pick a page at
random?
(Laughing.
)
>> SPEAKER: So, this is April
3rd.  It's one of the pages that
doesn't
have a  marker, but, um, in
1959, on
April 3rd, Robert Frost was here
.  The problem with a lot of
these signatures is they're
really hard to read.
Gary Gilsner was here from Iowa.
It was first signed in 1953 by a
woman named Christine whose last
name I cannot read from New
York, New York.
>> SPEAKER: And we could page
through this book, and you'll
have a chance to take a look at
it afterwards for the people in
the audience, and we'll post as
many pictures as we can for the
people who are listening along,
um, when I was, when I saw this
book the first  time, I think we
picked three pages,
more or less at random.
On the second page was Robert
Frost, and on the third page,
three lines apart
from each other were Alan
Gisburg and Paul  Simon, and
what I love about the book is
that it offers these connections
between people that you, as
somebody who knows American
poetry inside and out, or me, as
somebody who does not know
American poetry very well, um,
can, in
our minds, kind of come up with
a connection between these
poets.  One of the things that
we're going to be talking about
throughout the course of this
podcast are things that act
exactly like this book.
They're things that act as a
kind of instrument to play a
wide collection of,
in this case, kind of poets and,
um, and their work.
Um, one of the, um, most
interesting things that I, um, I
imagine about this, and this is
where I get a little bit, I was
going to use the word poetic,
it's not the right word.
>> SPEAKER: Feel free.
>> SPEAKER: On a day like
today, can we find today in the
book?  We have this instrument
which allows us to kind of
conjure a list of poets,
and in my head, um, these poets
would be sitting together in
this room, and they would have a
kind of dialogue with each
other.  Who do we have today?
>> SPEAKER: Today, we have Tom
Stoperned from 1982 and Wilbert
Snow
from
1961, M Travers from 1954, and a
lot of other people who
just have terribly legibility.
(Laughing.)
>> SPEAKER: Various other
people.  It's actually a pretty
full day.  It's one of those
days that makes it
hard for, um, contemporary
readers to find a place to sign.
>> SPEAKER: It would be a
crowded day in the Catburg feed,
if we were going to get all of
them together.
Um, one question that I, um,
that I wanted to ask you is,
it's sort of
related to this, but it's more
of a discussion about a new
position that you've, I think
just this year, um, come
up with, which is the, um, is it
called the youth poet laureate?
>> SPEAKER: It's not our
position.
>> SPEAKER: Oh, it's not?
>> SPEAKER: No, no, and in
fact, for
many years, um, we avoided
having
anything to do with other poet
laureate positions because of
the fact that we have this law
that established our position,
and it is a U.S. position.
So, this year, we featured the
national youth poet laureate,
part of a
program that comes from New York
City, a nationwide program.  We
featured the first ever youth
poet
laureate, giving the opening
reading for
our new poet laureate,  Tracy
Kay Smith, so that was a big
deal.
We've also been subsequently
featured at youth  events,
including one coming
up in just a week, but one of
the great
joys of this job is that the,
and of the institution is the
opportunity to champion the work
that other organizations are
doing, other individuals are
doing to promote poetry,
because the laureateship, and
because
the library is so
instrumental to our creative
life and a sort of understanding
of what libraries do.  So, it's
a great place to bring people
like Amanda Gorman, who's a real
firecracker of a first youth
poet laureate, to the library.
>> SPEAKER: If people do want
to get involved with what the
poetry department is doing, you
have a blog which you've
been running since 2012 that you
can find at  blogs.llc.
gov/catburg, right?
>> SPEAKER: Yep.
>> SPEAKER: And are there any
interesting events coming up?
>> SPEAKER: Yeah.
April 19th, our current poet
laureate, Tracy Kay Smith, will
give her closing, really, more
of a talk, and for the
first time, it'll be followed by
a
monitored discussion
.  It should be a really
noteworthy event.
In the room across the way.
>> SPEAKER: I have one more
question, and this is a selfish
one.  Have you thought about
getting this book digitized?
>> SPEAKER: Um, no, but, um, I
was
seated next to one of your
guests who I talked to about
maybe repairing the book a
little bit, because there's a
page that's coming out, and it
could use a little love.
>> SPEAKER: Well, you just give
me the best cue responsible for
our next guest.  Thank you,
Robert.
>> SPEAKER: My pleasure.
(Applause.
)
(Singing.)
>> SPEAKER: That was the
transition you should have heard
earlier.
>> SPEAKER: Better late than
never.
>> SPEAKER: This is the next
transition.
(Singing.
)
>> SPEAKER: He was an
extraordinary man, not in the
least for the figure he cut.
He'd often be spotted wearing a
broad
black hat, a long cigarette
holder with a long cigarette.
He worked in his pajamas,
wearing a turbine and a yellow
dressing gown, with red slippers
that turned up at the toes.
He wrote, or so it's told only
by the light of 41 candles.
Our next guest is Adrienne, who
is a
senior photo conservator.
Adrienne, welcome to Artist in
the
Archive speak.
>> SPEAKER: Thank you so much.
It's an honor.
>> SPEAKER: Now, you have had a
chance
to dig into Haulenhollenday's
career.  Can you tell us the
story about how that happened?
>> SPEAKER: Well, it started
because I
work here at the library, and we
have
the best collection of Holenday
probably in the world, we have
the largest, for sure,
collection, it came directly
from
his estate, and I became very
interested in just learning
about how people, I wanted to do
a project where I, um,
created a material-based catalog
to really show how people could
look at photographs as  objects,
not just as
images, and the collection
really stood
out as something that had
incredible
depth, and, so, I was awarded a
fellowship in 2012 to really
look into his  work, and as a
conservator, I did that in a
materials way, so looking at all
of his papers and the way he
mounts things and how he
processes things and
everything, so I looked at all
700, well, before, we had
730-something, and
now, we have found
750-something.
>> SPEAKER: So, in total, you
have --
>> SPEAKER: 752 at my last
count.
>> SPEAKER: Okay.
So, we have a few of the, we
tried to
get the prints here, but they're
very important.
(Laughing.)
>> SPEAKER: They needed an
armed escort or something like
that, and we didn't want guns in
this room, so we said no.
(Laughing.)
>> SPEAKER: We're going to show
you, um, some digital images,
and, um, Joel is going to
describe a couple of them
for us, but not this particular
image.  I know you picked a few
images that represent a kind of
span --
>> SPEAKER: Yeah, things that
he's known to have photographed
in his career, kind of periods
of his work.
So, this one is, um, he's known
for
male nudes, and this male nude
was made
probably in 1898, 1899, and it's
of
someone that we imagine, well,
the archival record doesn't
really tell us all that much,
but we imagine that they were
probably lovers, or he
definitely
had a romantic interest in this
fellow.
So, this is Thomas Harris, and
he's in
the pose of a dying slave,
inspired by Michelangelo's Dying
Slave.  I always loved this
piece.
>> SPEAKER: And this image?
>> SPEAKER: This is what he's
most known for, which is his
focus on sacred
subjects, where he reenacted the
passion
of Christ, and, so, on the cross
here,
you see Holenday  himself, and
he, um,
kind of created this cross and
crucified
himself, like, with ropes, but,
well, he was very zen anyway,
but he grew his beard and his
hair, and he reenacted the
road to Cal very, the
crucifixion, and you can show
the next one, which is, I think
the last words of Christ, so the
last thoughts that Christ
thought, dying
on the cross, and then he also
did the resurrection.
>> SPEAKER: Joel has a
description for this image.
>> SPEAKER: This is a series of
seven
crucifixion images set out
horizontally, but each is
focused on the head of the
bearded Christ, wearing a crown
of thorns.
The images are set between
drawings of columns.  From left
to right, Christ, with eyes
reflecting a forlorn weariness
gazes off into the right.
Then to the left, downcast, and
to the right with eyes closed,
with his mouth
and eyes open wide.  I'll turn
to the left and up.  Then with
eyes cast downward.  Next, with
his head back and eyes closed,
lips slightly parted, and
finally, with eyes closed and
his head lying on his right
shoulder.
The column  Words appear.
Father, forgive them, they know
not what they do.
Today, thou shall be with me in
paradise.
My God, my God, why has thou
forsaken me?
Into thy hands, I commend my
spirit.  It is finish finished.
>> SPEAKER: This image is so
striking.
>> SPEAKER: Isn't that
incredible?
I'm just fascinated by this.
This image was done, um, as
Holenday
had, in 1904, a, like,
catastrophic studio fire, and he
lost many of his prints and most
of his negatives in that fire,
and most people consider his
career over at that point, but,
actually, I think that the work
that he does after that studio
fire is even more spectacular
than the work that he did before
it, and this image comes a year
after that studio fire.
So, he went to, um, the  Hampton
Normal and Agricultural School
in  Hampton, Virginia, which is
now Hampton  University, and he
took photographs
there of the faculty and the
students.
They had a camera club, so he
went to work with the students
there, and I just think the
images from Hampton are some of
his best.
I love how she's so, um,
shadowed in
the front, and then the girl
behind her is, like, luminous.
>> SPEAKER: And Joel has a
description of this image as
well, because I think it's just
wonderful.
>> SPEAKER: A black and white
photograph, rectangular and set
vertically, an interior of a
room with a curtained window at
righted.  In the foreground at
right is the
silhouette of a black woman.  To
the left and behind her is a
younger black female in a bright
white dress, her hair adorned
behind her head
with a white bow.
>> SPEAKER: One more image, and
then we'll get deep into what
these images are, because I
think it's fascinating.
>> SPEAKER: Yeah, so, he did a
lot of
allegorical subjects, the
prodigal son, and this one is
part of a series called Orpheus.
I just really liked the, um, the
composition of this, the way
it's it's printed, and you'll
see in a lot of the images we
showed, he has a unique way of
mounting these images on these
multi-layered paper supports.  I
just think they add a lot to the
feeling and the tension
surrounding the
image, and he was kind of the
inventor of this style of
mounting, which became
known as the American style.
>> SPEAKER: Day was part of a
photography movement called the
Photo Successionests,  right?  I
love this term.
Apparently, it was chosen mainly
because they felt like it was a
very
abrasive term, and Alfred, who
was one of the other founders,
had this
conversation that I stumbled
upon in which she said what is
photo succession, and am I a
photo successionests?  And he
said, well, do you feel like you
are one?  He said that's all
there is to it.
>> SPEAKER: You were, if he
said you  were, and actually,
Day was part of  pictorialism,
but not so much photo
succession, because photo
secession
succession, you needed, they
actually were not simpatico, so
he was never part of the formal
movement, although his art is
really part of that movement.
>> SPEAKER: I think what you're
just describing about the
objects sits really well with
kind of that movement, which was
said that what was significant
about a photograph was not what
was in front of the camera, but
the manipulation of the image by
the photographer, and I'm
generalizing, but, um, so, talk
about
how these photographs physically
were made, because I think it's
different from what we would
sometimes imagine.
>> SPEAKER: Yeah, so, with this
particular era of photography,
they were really trying to
legitimize photography and kind
of put it on the same level as
other types of art, like drawing
and painting, and one of the
ways that they
did that was through the
manipulation of the print.  One
of the processes that  allowed
for
this really, um, varied
manipulation was called the
platinum process.  So, almost,
not everything Day ever made,
but most everything he ever
printed in his career was made
using the platinum printing
process, and platinum
is basically a paper support,
and then
the image is actually made with
platinum metal that's deposited
into the fibers
of that paper, and, so, they're
extremely stable, if made
correctly, and they were called
the prints of
prophecies, because it has this
incredible richness and kind of
what we call dynamic  range, the
levels between
the bright white and the dark
dark
.
>> SPEAKER: I think there are
some
artists, and our next guest will
have experience with this, who
are meticulous in their
recording of when a work was
made and how it was made and so
on and so on.  It sounds to me
like a lot of your work is
trying to, like, puzzle together
the sort of true dates of some
of these works.
Maybe some people in the room
know this, but some do not, but
in the basement of the Madison
Building,
there's a full, like, forensic
laboratory that could totally be
out of a television show.  It's
really amazing.  Can you talk
about, like, the actual
techniques that you're using to
try to make some sense of this
large collection of images?
>> SPEAKER: Yeah, so, one of
the things I'm using is just
really systematic looking, like
understanding how these
processes work and really
cataloging all
of the different variations
that, um, that an artist could
use in making them.
So, that might include just,
like I said, cataloging
systematically the mouth, but
also looking at the elemental
composition of the image.
So, really looking at how that
image
was made, and you can't always
do that with your eye, so one of
the techniques
we use is x-ray florescent, a
non-disruptive technique, and
you point an x-ray beam at the
image, and it excites the atoms
and gives you a spectrum of the
elements that are in that sheet
of paper, and if you take that
spectra and combine it with a
knowledge of the prophecies, you
can really determine what type
of technique they were using.
So, in the first image that we
looked
up with the Dying Slave of
Thomas  Harris, it's a platform
print, so it contains platinum,
but it also contains a large bit
of mercury, so we know it
was a mercury platinum print,
which gives it this brown tone.
So,ert, artists tended to use
certain techniques, so you can
start to understand how much
manipulation they're doing when
they transfer from one technique
to another, and it can help you
date and transfer images to
them.
>> SPEAKER: One thing I didn't
bring up with our last guest
that I could have brought up was
that the poetry department is
sometimes either responsible for
or becomes the conduit
to new discoveries of poems that
are  attributed.  I know that
fairly recently, there was
a new Walt Whitman poem that was
discovered from the manuscripts
department, or, sorry, the
periodicals department, a poem
that was labeled WW, and
somebody thought, well, maybe
this
could very well be a Whitman.
Have there been photographs that
we
didn't know there were
Holendays that we now know are?
>> SPEAKER: Yes, actually.
There was an interesting case
where the curator brought down a
print that
had come in through the Clarence
White collection, and Holenday
and White were really good
friends, he was godfather to one
of their kids, and they had a
very close working relationship.
They both did photographs at the
same time, so sometimes, it can
be difficult
when photographers are working
kind of with the same subjects
and stuff to tell who's making
what print.  This print came
down, it came in through the
Clarence White collection, but
it was unattributed, and through
my work on cataloging all of his
protoographic mounts and his
techniques,
I was able to link that print to
Day, and then I started really
looking at the literature,
trying to find any references
that might, um, be somewhere,
and I was able to find a print
mounted almost in exactly the
same manner that was published,
so it was kind of the
cataloging and then looking at
the historic literature, and we,
um, we've been able to attribute
quite a few
images that were misattributed
or unattributed to Day now in
our collection, I think a total
of six images that we've been
able to clarify the attribution.
>> SPEAKER: Last episode, um,
we talked about an experiment
that somebody in the
labs department did, who's
sitting two rows back, so over
here, made a really excellent
little tool that takes, um,
photographs and breaks them down
into
small color palates, which you
can use to, um, read across an
archive of photographs.  I can
imagine one of the challenges
is, like, how do you hold more
than the five images we've seen
today in your
mind for long enough to
remember, like, and, so, the
conversion of these photographs
into data, I think greatly
assists that process.
>> SPEAKER: Absolutely.
>> SPEAKER: And I know that
that is some of the work that
you're looking to do, right, is
the sort of, so, I hate this
term, but I'll use it once, the
kind of big data techniques to
analyze the catalog, or the
collection as a whole.  Can you
talk a little about what you're
doing?
>> SPEAKER: Yeah. Just with
Day or other things too?
>> SPEAKER: In general.
>> SPEAKER: I'm just really
interested  in, I mean,
conservators are very good at
systematic looking, it's kind
of,
it's part of the job
description, so, um, but we
haven't been so good
necessarily at recording that in
a way over time where we could
start to really
see what that data told us
beyond what an individual object
brings to the table, but really
looking at hundreds of things,
and then what does that data
tell us about things that we may
never have noticed before.  So,
you  know, I did that with Day,
and it's led to the redating of
some of the prints, the
reattribution of many of the
prints.
Right  now, I'm also looking at,
um, Civil War maps, so that's
one thing that I'm looking at
with big data, but I think,
actually, the most exciting one
I'm working on right now is
looking in the collections, the
general collections
books, we have 78,000 books that
are on photographic
technologies, so, of  course, my
head, like, exploded, because
it was so incredible, it's one
of my favorite places on Earth,
and I know
that makes me a total  nerd, but
it was, like, so amazing, and
then you open
these books, and you realize
there are actually photographs
in that books.  When
conservators can see photographs
of a known date and then we
would have the recipes for how
they made them, I was like, oh
my gosh, we should start to mine
this, and I call it mapping the
genome of 19th century
manufactured photography.
So, how do we take it beyond
just one sample and actually
start to catalog this data so
that it can show us new things
about photography that was
manufactured in the 19th
century?  So, we've started to
mine the 1500 samples that we
have collected, and we're seeing
things like corporate  takeovers
and photography that were
happening in the 1880s, you
know, and it's, like, just
really fascinating things that
we never would have understood
before.
So, I think it has, it's a dirty
business.
(Laughing.)
>> SPEAKER: That was part of
the reason that I wanted to have
this conversation with you
today, was to sort of get this
sense of what these types of
techniques
offer as a kind of way into this
largeness of an archive that is
otherwise sometimes, I think can
feel really impenetrable.
>> SPEAKER: Absolutely. We
have, you know, 16 million
photographs, so we have a lot of
work to do with mining it.
>> SPEAKER: And also, to learn
more about  Holenday.  I mean,
what an amazing individual.  I
know that, in some ways, Day was
a human version of this book,
right?
Where he was a kind of bridge
between
so many different people in so
many different times.  He
founded  Copeland and Day
Publishing, which was maybe most
famous for kind of publishing
this idea of kind of the small
magazine in-American
America in America, um, he was
part of a
club which included Bliss Carm
Carmenand all kinds of people,
and then I think my
favorite weird connection, so,
it was,
um, he was friends with a social
worker
named  Jesse, and one day, he
wrote Holenday a note, and the
note read I wonder if you may
happen to have an artist friend
who would care to be
interested in a little Syrian
boy
.  This story, it blows me away.
Is there one piece of
Holenday's amazing strangeness
that you want to leave with us?
>> SPEAKER: Well, I love that
he, he's fascinating to study
because of his meticulous
nature, which I think comes out
of his  publishing days, but
he's
also, he was such a generous
person, and
every letter that you see
written to him was thank you for
thinking of  me, thank you for
sending me this, thank you for
giving me my education,
sponsoring me for this, and, so,
I think, you know,
his work with him being able to
become the writer that he was
was in direct relationship to
him knowing  Holenday,
and, so, it just feels really
great to study someone who's so
fascinating, but
also such a wonderful human
being too.
>> SPEAKER: Well, speaking of
generosity, thank you for being
so generous with our time.
>> SPEAKER: Thank you so much
for having me.
(Applause.
)
>> SPEAKER: In the 1950s, the
mathematician and meteorologist
was thinking about the weather.
He was experimenting with
statistical forecasting, but he
found that his simulations
didn't match the messy, wet
reality of the real world.
Weather, right?
So, he setup to develop a
non-linear model that would
match the unpredictability of
nature.
In 1963, he published a paper
called
non-periodic  flow -- which laid
down the foundations for an
entire branch of mathematics
called chaos theory.  Chaos
systems are interesting in that
they start off quite
predictable.  After a certain
amount of time though, they
start to behave in a way which,
for
a lot of intents and purposes,
resembles randomness.  This is
why weather forecasters can only
predict the weather 10 days out.
One of the things that defines a
chaotic system is that it's
particularly sensitive to
initial conditions, that is the
state of the system when it
starts has a huge effect on how
it will behave long into the
future.  This idea that these
extraordinary, elaborate
mathematical structures could
be so dependent on minute
changes right at the beginning
eventually gave rise to a famous
term that he coined, the
butterfly effect.
His model, particularly the
Lorens attractor, is a set of
three  differential equations.
There are three constants which
define those at delicate initial
conditions that we spoke about.
By changing the values of these
numbers, the system can now put
a vast
menagerie of strange geometries,
set to a very particular
structure, set of
values, 28, 10 and 8 over 3, it
attracts a structure which looks
an awful lot like a butterfly.
It's when we watch that
butterfly emerge though by
setting the system free to
animate over time that we get a
real sense of the beauty of the
attractor.  We see how it lives
through long periods of
regularity, where we start to
recognize the pattern, only to
seemingly at random switch
course or change direction.
Joel, can you tell us what the
Lorens attractor looks like?
>> SPEAKER: Sure.
This image features swirls of
lines,
or is it one line, that turns
and curves
in two connected parts, each
comprised
of oval shapes, enlarging from a
core into the arched collection
of swirls.
At left, it leans to the left,
while
the right series of ovals leans
to the right.
Overall, two angled and menacing
eyes,
or a stark, colorless butterfly
on the wing.
>> SPEAKER: My third and last
guest today is Kathleen O'Neal.
Hi Kathleen.  Welcome to Artist
in the Archive.
>> SPEAKER: Hi.
>> SPEAKER: So, Kathleen was
one of the first people I met at
the library.
I went on this grand, um,
extraordinary tour of all the
rooms and as many of the
collections as I could get to,
and Kathleen showed us the
manuscript division, and at the
end of the tour, sort of more or
less offhand, she said, and over
there is the original Lorens
attractor software.
(Laughing.)
>> SPEAKER: And I, being me,
was like
oh my gosh, let's go see it,
and, so, we saw it, but maybe we
can start by talking a little
bit about the manuscript
division, what it holds, what
kinds of things belong in the
manuscript
division, and then we can move
on to the Lorens collection.
>> SPEAKER: The manuscript
division collects the personal
papers and
organizational records of, um,
people and organizations that
have cultural
significance to the United
States States, documents, the
cultural history, that means the
political arts, science, um, and
the every day lives of the
American people, and we have
over 11,000 collections.
Some are small, a single item,
others,
like the NAACP records, is
millions of items.  We mostly
collect manuscripts, but we do
have some 3D objects, we have
photographs, we have scrapbooks.
Um, there's an example of almost
any type of material you could
find, and now, as we're
collecting these, um, more
modern collections, we're
getting more digital materials.
So, that's our new frontier.
>> SPEAKER: If you look on the
library's Wikipedia page or
anywhere else, they'll give you
numbers for all of the other
departments about how much they
hold, and then for the
manuscripts department, they're
just like, seriously, lots.
That's how much it has.
>> SPEAKER: Well, they say 70
million items, but, of course,
it depends on how you count an
item.
>> SPEAKER: Right, and you have
some
items on your lap, and we'll
talk about this in a moment, but
you helped to process this
particular collection, right?
>> SPEAKER: The Lorens
collection came
to the library in about 2008,
2009, and it was processed by
Joseph brooks.  He processed the
paper, and the paper portion of
the collection is about
15,000 items, it's 44 boxes and
12 oversize boxes, which is a
relatively small collection for
the
manuscript division, but the
digital
materials that came in included
a CPU,
um, an 8-inch floppy, a couple
of 5 and a  quarter inch
floppies, 3 and a
quarter inch floppy and some
optimal disks, and at the time
they came in, we didn't have the
tools we  needed to process
those materials, but in the last
several years, and this is one
of the things I love about this
collection, is that, sometimes,
you have these collections that
draw you out into the
library, but you get you get to
draw on the expertise of other
divisions and
other people, and the
preservation has
been  developing, um, forensic
station down in preservation,
and Amanda May,
who has saved my life more than
once, um, developed a work flow
to recover the 5 and a quarter
inch floppies.  So, at that
point, um, which was about a
year or two ago, we thought we
were
ready to tackle the CPU and the
5 and a quarter inch floppies.
The 8-inch floppy will have to
wait for another day.
>> SPEAKER: We are going to use
some
real software from the 1980s and
70s
momentarily, but we'll get there
in a minute.  Um, the manuscript
department, this is not only
kind of a record of history
itself, but I think it also is
this scaffolding around history.
In this case, we have a
collection which starts near or
before the been
good beginning of modern
computation and
that ends very much in the
modern
computational era, and the
reason why I didn't show you a
picture when Joel described the
Lorens attractor is because this
is how it
existed in Edward Lorens' head
in the beginning, because the
computational power was not
available to render it.  Can you
show us the first diagram?
Yeah, this one.  We'll start
with this one.
And to give a sense of what that
process would have looked like
up on
stage, and we'll post this
image, it's a piece of graph
paper, right?  It's got marks on
it in pencil, and, so, you can
imagine that this grand idea,
which we'll talk in a second
about how this came up, because
I think it's really fascinating,
would have emerged
not as a whole, but as small
fragments
over a course of years and
decades.
>> SPEAKER: Yeah, I mean, I
think the thing that struck me
is because, as I
processed the digital, I didn't
ignore the paper, I  needed to
look at the paper so I could
understand the relationship
between the two, and a lot of
times, it was the paper that
told me what the born digital
materials were,
but, um, was how handmade
everything is
and the labor of scientific
work, which,
um, is so clear when you see all
these
tiny, little dots that needed to
be plotted.  Later, and we
talked about this, you know,
they've just run out of room,
the
graph paper is not big enough.
>> SPEAKER: That second image,
because
this is a great example of that,
where
Lorens begins to plot perhaps
the first plot of the attractor,
only to realize
that he's run out of graph paper
.
>> SPEAKER: Yeah
, that's half of it, and, so,
there's, um, lots of graph
paper, and also, there's
another, I'll just hold this one
up, this is sort of an expanded
version of that, and, so,
there's dozens of these, and if
you were really smart and knew
what you were doing, you could
lay them out on the floor like a
jigsaw
puzzle or a mosaic and put them
together.  Should I show the --
>> SPEAKER: Not yet. We'll
save that for the end.
I'll say what we're looking at
is kind of an 8.5 by 11 piece of
graph paper, and on it are
pencil, but also blue and red
ink
lines, something that, to my
mind,
represents the kind of, like,
quarrel inside of a snail shell,
it's kind of this little piece
of mathematics, which
to, um, Lorens, would have been
real proof of something that,
again, more or less, he would
have had to hold in his mind.
The Lorens attractor itself,
which we'll show in a second,
was born of a coincidence,
right?
>> SPEAKER: Yes.
>> SPEAKER: Can you tell us the
story?
>> SPEAKER: Well, the story he
tells in his book is he was
running this series
of data, and, um, the data had
gone out
to, um, six decimal points, and
because he wanted the numbers to
line up and not kick down to the
next line on the
printout, he rounded them to
three
decimal points, and, so, um, I
should
say, this computer took up half
of his office, it was incredibly
noisy, just the computer, not
even the printer, and the
printer was one of those, if any
of
you remember, and I do, the old
printers
with the sprockets, that you had
to pull the, what is the word?
(Off mic.)
>> SPEAKER: Thank you. Um, off
when you were done, that was
incredibly loud.  So, he goes
and gets a cup of coffee
and comes back, and he realizes
he wants
to run another set of data, and
instead of inputting the
original numbers, he
input the rounded numbers, and
he goes and gets another cup of
coffee, and he
comes back, and he is surprised
by what
he  sees, because initially, the
data tracked exactly with the
first plotting
of the data, but as, I think he
said it
takes about an hour or
something, as the timeline goes
on, the data starts converging,
and it's not behaving in the
way he expected it to.
>> SPEAKER: This story is
mindbowing mind-blowing to me.
So, the chaos theory was a slow
burn.  This paper was only cited
10 times in the following decade
by people outside of his
particular field, so it was not
an immediate success, but to put
it in a framing which I think it
deserves, it is said that when
we look back on the 20th
century, we will see three great
advances in math and physics,
those
being relativity, quantum
mechanics, and chaos.
So, this thing that came out of
a trip to get a cup of coffee
and a rounding error became
something really amazing.
>> SPEAKER: I just want to say,
one thing I noticed, I was
looking through a new folder the
other day in preparation for
today, and much of the
correspondence is people writing
to Lorens, saying can I get a
copy of your paper, it's out of
print.
>> SPEAKER: Yeah.
>> SPEAKER: So, and he credits
another
scientist for handing out copies
of his
papers to people for the spread
of the
idea and its application in
economics and physiology and
other areas.
>> SPEAKER: Everywhere.
>> SPEAKER: Yeah.
>> SPEAKER: And actually, so,
we're going to show some
software here, and I think in
almost all cases, the software
we're showing you is written by
people who were interested in
the applications of chaos theory
in other fields.
>> SPEAKER: Yes.
>> SPEAKER: So, this first one
that I think we'll show is this,
um, this
software by Jackson at the
Center for , and I'll, um, I'll
show you a little bit about how
this works, and then we can, um,
talk a little bit.
I'm going to ask for, um, an
entrainment goal.  This is so
exciting, isn't it?
(Laughing.
)
>> SPEAKER: The initial
conditions are really going to
change the way this
runs, but you've been holding
the Lorens attractor in your
head, and now we get to see in
it.  Do you remember what year
this software was --
>> SPEAKER: Um, you know what?
I have it on a piece of paper
over there.  I don't remember
off the top of my head, but I
can tell you later.
>> SPEAKER: So, the yellow line
is the
one that's going to render this
sort of
classic, um, Lorens attractor
forum, and you'll notice that
what it does is kind of similar
to what I was describing before,
where it follows these kind of
periods where you think you know
what it's going to do next, and
then it does something that you
don't know it will do next, and
I think there's an important
delineation to be made here
between randomness and chaos.
The system is not random, but
it's chaotic, which I think is a
really interesting division to
make, right?
If it were random, this computer
couldn't simulate it, but
because it has these kind of
three equations driving it, it
does continue, um, you know, we
can run this essentially
forever, getting, eventually,
this really beautiful butterfly
form that we're used to.
>> SPEAKER: I'm not going to
speak to the mathematics of it,
but I, my, you know, my
understanding of it is there
wouldn't be a butterfly if it
was truly
chaotic, because it wouldn't,
the image
wouldn't recreate every time,
you would
have a different image.
>> SPEAKER: Um, there is
another piece of software, I
don't have the name of this.
>> SPEAKER: This is, um,
actually by
Mike  Page and Jim -- who
created it for -- I hope I
pronounced his name correctly.
>> SPEAKER: So, I have this one
all cued up, and I hope that the
sound is going to work here.
Otherwise, I'm going to do some
really
good, like, 1980s computer
sounds for you all, because
that's the kind of, um, thing
that we're looking for here.
We're going to do the
experiment, we're going to get
some data, so I'm
going to load this data file
.  We'll load that data, and
now, I'm
going to go plot that data.  I
think we're ready.  Are you
ready for it?
(Beeping.)
>> SPEAKER: I think it's easy
for some of us to laugh when we
look at this software, but I
think it's important to realize,
with this one and for the one we
saw last, for these
mathematicians and scientists,
this is, in many cases, the
first time they were seeing this
thing.
It was this first confirmation
of something that I think they
must have felt was something
amazing, and to see it, or to
hear  it, it must have been a
revolution.
>> SPEAKER: There's only a few
letters
that are associated with the
software in this collection, but
the letters that are, you get
the sense, like, this is your
data, you know, they're writing
to him, I created this to show
your data,
and, um, Lorens also said, um,
at one point that, you know,
it's the ability
to do, um, change the variables,
it's not the initial computation
that's so difficult, he said,
you know, people did these kind
of computations way back to the
Greeks, it's the need to do
multiple variations on it.  He
said I probably would have given
up
without a computer.
>> SPEAKER: The earliest
software that we have, we
couldn't get running.
>> SPEAKER: Yeah, that's 1986.
>> SPEAKER: He said micro
computers permit the researcher
to create a much more flexible
environment than is generally
possible with large computers.
So, here, I think a big benefit
to see what was happening here
compared to, like, that old room
size computer that you were
talking to was there was the
flexibility to kind of see these
things
over and over and over again,
and, actually, I was talking to
one of our
previous guests who reminded me,
he is a topologist and a
mathematician, that it's
important that we don't talk
about Lorens discovering this
thing, because it already was
there, right?
Well, let's show one more thing,
because it's the best, and
sometimes, I think by looking at
the materials, you get some
sense of the person.  We heard
this from our last guest.  We
can look at those photographs
and get some sense of a person.
That can sometimes be harder to
get
from computational diagrams and
from plots on graph paper, but
we have something really
delightful that was part of the
Lorens collection.
>> SPEAKER: Um, and I'm going
to show
the scientific version of it
first.  This is, um, I'm not
sure whether this is the
butterfly   turns in a different
angle or whether there's
different variables happening
here, but it
clearly, to me, looks like a
heart, and
again, this is one of the
delightful
things about the handmade
element of
this collection, is, um, there's
the, a computer-generated
version of  it, and
then down here, I was like, why
is it printed on the right side
of the paper?  Well, on the
bottom, it says I'm strangely
attracted to you.
(Laughing.)
>> SPEAKER: So, he was making a
valentine valentine.
(Laughing.)
>> SPEAKER: Or sending a
message of
love, perhaps to his his wife,
we don't know, but it  makes you
wonder, and that's what I love
about it.
>> SPEAKER: Thank you,
Kathleen.
(Applause.
)
(Singing.
>> SPEAKER: We're taught in
high school that math exists
inside of cartesian coordinates.
The fact is that math doesn't
care about or for our made-up
axes.  Indeed, we can setup a
Lorens attractor inside any
space we can imagine, real world
space or  computational space or
emotional space or flavor space
or whatever we want.  I wanted
you to imagine for a moment that
the room you're in or the bus or
the subway car is filled with
words.  Every word in the
English language, floating in
space.
Over there by the door is a
cluster of
fruit words, pear and apple and
orange.  Right under your chair
are all of the synonyms for
love.  Above your head are hope
and dreams and imagination.
Proper nouns are here as well in
dense clusters.  The presidents
are over near the window.  Just
beside them are all the
countries
and states and providences and
cities.  If you look back at
that cluster of fruits by the
door, you'll see that the apple
has been pulled closer to New
York, drawn to it by so many pop
cultural references.  As an
experiment, I thought I'd build
the attractor in this word space
and see if the path of the
butterfly could be used to
generate a series of words that
might resemble some sort of
geometric poetry, so I used a
corpus of 3 million English
language words and their
relationships to create this
three-dimensional map of
language.  I let the attractor
do its thing
inside of this gigantic word
cloud and recorded the results.
Now, remember, these attractors
are very sensitive to initial
conditions, so making small
changes really affects the
sculpture of their attractor and
thus the kind of so-called poem
that they output.
So, um, here is word space, and,
um,
word space is a
three-dimensional object, so,
um, on the screen in front of
me, there's a cloud of points,
each
representing a word, and these
words are clustered as in the
example I described, so certain
related words will be in one
place, so I can, um, jump over
maybe to
a series of words that are
somewhat related, there's
balancing and coordinate next to
each other, and I'll
jump over, um, to, um, some
proper nouns
like we described, and then,
finally,
I'll jump over, um, to this
little
narrow tinderal of years, which
are so often found next to each
other in our text.  So, what
happens if we let the Lorens
attractor loosen loose in the
space?
Well, we see our now familiar
butterfly shape appear, and we
can ask
for that butterfly to give us
some poems.
Now, with Robert in the room, I
want to be careful, that these
are not, in
fact, poems, but they are
structures of words which help
us maybe explore this
vast and confusing space of
language.
Now, this particular poem, I'm
not going to take a chance to
read, but I
will, um, read to you a few of
the
outputs that came out of this
software,
if I can find my notes amongst
this
gigantic pile of things
.
This dynamic ride  itself sounds
this variable declaration.
This online spell, it sounds
this online location.  The ranks
of beauty, one is beauty, and
the beauty attribute is one,
imported of its  export.
Review and export, of the export
imported of export, and of the
export of
its obstacles matches the
symbolic to itself.  Supply the
sustainable caring, supply
the  placement, the caring of
the review, supply the rank and
the rank of
the symbolics.
Reply the export, reply
obstacles, thinking, licensing.
Reply the obstacles, the
obstacles
symbolic, warring obstacles.
Yes, specialty and  specialty,
imported and natural, its
self-natural grace, grace,
translation, and reply match
translations.  The translation,
the translation of
the translation's travel and
dates and objectives and
objects.  Objection to host its
host.
A crash printed -- an innovative
and explosive demand.  Lit of.
Lit of demand.  This variable,
variable spell,
imported of this variable talk,
younger genius, of
crossification and this
competitive supply,
crossification, this
competitive, competitive spell.
Reply the symbolic reporting.
Reply the specialty, the
reporting of the translation
translation.
Supply the demand.  Supply mode
of feeling, proceeding,
classification.  Supply these
announcements.  These
announcements competitive.
Warring statements.  Now, I
should mention a little bit
about how this is constructed,
because
it's not, in fact, an exact
random block throughLorens
space.  Well, it is, but those
words are then
sent to a  poetic structure.
Robert, can you guess the
structure?  Walt Whitman was the
structure of that poem, which I
thought conducted itself
nicely to the kind of weird
randomness of it, and again, I
don't feel that these things are
themselves poets, but the way of
using the spirit of Whitman to
explore this linguistic space in
a way which we might find to be
interesting or intriguing.
Now, as I  mentioned, Kathleen
showed me the Lorens attractor
on the first day of my
residency, and since then, it's
been in the front of my mind.
As I'm approaching the end of my
time here, I hope that my own
creative path will have a lot in
common with the strange
attractor.  It may have started
in predictable space, following
an expecting pattern, but now is
the time, I hope, that it veers
wildly into chaos.
Now, push all those words out of
the
room, sweep them down the drain,
push them out of the windows.
Let's instead fill the room with
everything the library holds,
all the maps and manuscripts and
objects and interviews and, of
course, books.  So many books.
Let's put all the tweets in
there too and the websites.
Like our words, these library
things are now organized by
their relationships, that big,
messy ball in the center is the
Civil War.
Holenday is, we can all agree,
off in the corner somewhere.
I've been thinking a lot about
how we as humans  navigate this
space, through
the website or  in-person, in
one of the library's reading
rooms.
We  If we plotted one course, it
would almost always show up as
one little
point, a densely tangled knot
occupying one space in this vast
galaxy, and that's because we
come to the library with
something to find, we come to
the library with something to
seek.  Our paths are nothing
like those elegant sweeps of the
Lorens attractor.  Now, I was
born in 1975, I got my first
computer when I was 9.  When I
went to university in 1993, I
taught Internet classes in the
library.  There were two words
that I would use
a lot back then, 25 years ago,
that are rarely ever used at all
when we talk about the Internet.
Those words are hyper and surf.
The term hyper comes from
mathematics, it refers to an
extension, a generalization, a
kind of radical opening.
The word surf comes, well, from
surfing.  To surf the web was to
be carried off by a force of
curiosity, not quite sure where
you're headed.
So far in my residency, I've
made abstract maps and strange
clocks and wide color palates.
I've put together artist's names
and strange lists for cocktail
parties and
I've turned the Lorens attractor
into a
vehicle
, to bring hyper back, to bring
surfing back, to find non-linear
waves through this building and
amongst all the
wonderful things that it holds,
all
these strange paths untrodden.
>> SPEAKER: The end of the
trail.
Copy of German invasion plan
found by
Captain Candy shortly after the
great allied bombing of October
1944, which marked the last
phase of German retreat
from Greece.  One map, color, on
tracing linen, 52 by 34
centimeters.
>> SPEAKER: Showing the rock as
it  appeared at the end of the
working
season and the method of landing
--
inaudible --
>> SPEAKER: Selma to Montgomery
marchers wave American flags in
front of the Alabama state
capitol at the end of
their 5-day march.  One
photographic print.
>> SPEAKER: This time, it
vanished
quite slowly, beginning with the
end of
the tale and ending with the
grin.
>> SPEAKER: Alice in
Wonderland, Herbert  Block,
1977, 1 drawing, graphite and
ink, brush with opaque
white over blue pencil
underdrawing with
overlay, 57.7 by 35.
8 centimeters.
>> SPEAKER: After the end of
World War  II, shown bomb
damage.
Unknown photographer,
photographer, 1946, 1
photographic print.
>> SPEAKER: Unknown
photographer, 1865, 1
photographic print.
>> SPEAKER: What in the end
will settle this war?  Trained
men.  It is your duty to become
one.  Enlist now.
>> SPEAKER: London,
paramilitary
recruiting company, 1915, 1
print,
poster,  lithograph, color, 75
by 25 centimeters.
>> SPEAKER: The dream at the
end of the
world and the literary renegade
-- inaudible -- 381 pages.
>> SPEAKER: Our differences
have nothing to do with the end
result we are seeking.
Herbert Block, 1952, 1 drawing.
>> SPEAKER: Nearing the end of
a noble
life,
-- inaudible -- 1908, 1
photographic
print on stereo card.
>> SPEAKER: The end of the
world as we
know it and other entertainment,
1979,
153  pages.
>> SPEAKER: Twelve pieces for
the end
of the century, 2005, 2 volumes
of music.
>> SPEAKER: To see the Earth
before the
end of the world, 2010, 161
pages.
>> SPEAKER: Everyone says that
at the
end of the world.
>> SPEAKER: Poem for the end of
time
and other poems, 2006, 59 pages.
>> SPEAKER: The end of the
civic
repertory theater, 1938, 1
portfolio, 14 photographic
points.
>> SPEAKER: The end of the
world is Los
Angeles, 1982, 94 pages.
>> SPEAKER: Is this the end of
the experiment?
Herbert Block, 1946, 1 drawing.
>> SPEAKER: A creek at the end
of the
lawn, 2012, 124 pages.
>> SPEAKER: The ice at the end
of the
world, Robert Seagull, 1994, 234
pages.
>> SPEAKER: Wallace Stevens,
1971.
>> SPEAKER: Is this the end of
little  Rico?
Daniel Ort, 1998, 72 pages.
>> SPEAKER: At the end of the
woods,
woods, 1924, 190 pages, last two
pages blank.
>> SPEAKER: At the end of the
open
road, Lewis Simpson,
1973.
>> SPEAKER: The end of the
titanic in
the sea, one score, five leaves.
>> SPEAKER: The end of summer
, 1986, 1 score, 48 pages.
>> SPEAKER: The end of the
novel of
love, 1997, 165 pages.
>> SPEAKER: The end of the
class war.
alphabet.
>> SPEAKER: The end of the
rainbow.
straight and narrow.
>> SPEAKER: The end of the 19th
century.
>> SPEAKER: The end of the
story --
(Inaudible.
)
>> SPEAKER: The end of the
matter.
affair.
>> SPEAKER: The end of
everything, man.
innocence, 1989,
1 score, 64 pages.
>> SPEAKER: Then we came to the
end, 476 pages.
>> SPEAKER: Praise to the end,
1951, 89 pages pages.
(Inaudible.
)
>> SPEAKER: The end --
inaudible -- 1992, 11 pages of
music.
>> SPEAKER: The end, 1927, 1
print, wood engraving.
>> SPEAKER: The end, 2008, 336
pages.
>> SPEAKER: The end, 1983, 1
sound cassette, 30 minutes.
>> SPEAKER: The end, 1974, 1
sound disk
.
(Singing.
)
>> SPEAKER: As always, we'll
post links
to all the materials we featured
in the  podcast.
(Applause.
)
>> SPEAKER: So, a couple
things.  Um, we're going to go
to the capitol lounge for some
drinks after this, if you want
to hang out and talk, so that's
right across the street, the
capitol lounge.
It is fun and, um, it's like a
bowling alley without the
bowling, so we're going to go
there.  That's awesome.  We have
a little bit of time left in
this room, so there's a chance
to see the objects and to talk
to the people
that I've been interviewing
want.  Otherwise, this is not
the last episode, I hope that
I'll have three
more for you before the end of,
um, my time here.  The next one
will feature some more science
and conservation, which is all
really exciting, and then the
episode after, I am interviewing
someone you may have heard of,
Dr. Carla Hayden, the  librarian
of Congress, so I'm looking
forward to that, but I hope
you'll subscribe and tell all
your friends, and thank you so
much.
(Applause.)